blake shelton and gwen stefani are
proving that they are more in love than
ever
with their brand new duet happy anywhere
the power couple debuted the romantic
new track on thursday night and
performed it for the first time on
television
on the today show's summer 2020 city
music series
next to you is kind of overrated
let it twist my homes wherever your
heart is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're always my destination
[Music]
i just love them and they always look so
happy together
now the country crooner also opened up
about how he and gwen have been spending
their time together in quarantine
admitting
that they finally have time to do the
things they were never able to do in the
past
we've been doing things that i've wished
i had time to do
uh you know for the last 20 years i
guess
and and that's and that's literally you
know stupid things like
uh you know pic pick blackberries you
know we're here actually here
this year during the time that
blackberries are arrived so we went and
picked blackberries we
grew a garden i grew several acres of
sweet corn
i literally acres country things like
that
after their intimate performance on
today the couple premiered the
romantic music video for the song which
was shot entirely at lakes oklahoma
ranch
so during a special live stream event in
support of the track
warner music nashville revealed that
gwen's brother todd stefani
shot the music video in 105 degree heat
while quarantined with the couple take a
look
[Music]
now my favorite part of the video is all
of the archival footage from gwen's
phone which she said
tells the totality of her and blake's
relationship now also during the
livestream event
blake gushed all about his life and
success admitting
i have the easiest job at this point in
my life and it's a blast to be a country
singer and do what i do
it's hilarious that listening to the
radio the last couple of years
that gwen stefani is going to be singing
the countries song to come out of
nashville it's ironic
it's funny of course happy anywhere
follows the couple's platinum certified
multi-week number one nobody but you
which marked blake's 27th chart topper
and gwen's first ever number one on the
country charts
and according to blake gwen was shocked
by the song's success and has become a
huge
country music fan ever since they
started dating she
she just never imagined hearing herself
on
on the country radio and she's been been
listening
you know for the last five years i guess
and and uh has really
fallen in love with with country music
she knew some country music the old
school stuff
we first started hanging out but now
she's kind of up to date on on
everything and everybody out there and
so now when we're driving down the road
and we hear uh
you know uh nobody but you come on the
radio it's she's still like what
what the hell happened how did this
happen you know so what do you think of
happy anywhere
and are you loving the music video as
much as me sound off in the comments
below